so sheriffs and immigration and customs
enforcement employees
are now suing the biden administration
they're accusing the administration of
blocking federal officials from doing
their jobs
and you know the surge of illegal
immigrants across our border is showing
no signs of slowing down
republicans are railing against the
president's border policies which are
just a reversal of what donald trump had
done
in the office congressman bob goode
warned
the u.s has quote no operational control
of the border
after he got a firsthand look at the
situation
texas senator ted cruz with this
right now i think their hands are tied
because they've made the promises
they're not going to go back on those
promises i don't believe
so joe biden will not be willing to
enforce the border
or stop the illegal immigration so his
only solution to the border crisis
is like an ostrich stick his head in the
sand and hope that the media doesn't
cover it
republican congressman andy biggs of
arizona co-chair of the house border
security caucus and you're also a member
of the
judiciary and oversight committees
congressman great to have you on the
program
the the idea of sticking one's head in
the sand uh
first of all talk to me about what biden
and his administration are refusing to
see about the border crisis
well harris they're virtually not seeing
anything they don't get the numbers
they're releasing people
into the country just enormous numbers
10 000 children unaccompanied children
alone recently and
released into the country 78 000
children unaccompanied children have
come to the country this year that's
like five times more than the highest
ever
they don't see the numbers they don't
see the impact that it has on the border
so
when kamala harris vice president kamala
harris goes to the board and goes to el
paso
she doesn't go to the areas along the
border that are hardest hit
so they don't see anything um except for
they don't want to bring the trump
policies back in
now trump policies gave us operational
control so they're virtually missing
uh uh harris they're missing the entire
picture of what's going on in my opinion
look some of your colleagues in the
house representatives steve scalise
and uh also tony gonzalez laid out a
couple of things that
the president can do to fight the border
prices i i know we put kamala harris in
charge of it but since nothing is
happening there
the best things the president could do
according to them right now
are to reject talk of rescinding title
42 of the public health safety act
which allows border patrol to turn away
illegals who
were recently in a country with a
contagious disease
and reverse his executive order that
stopped all border wall construction
and repealed president trump's remain in
mexico policy
scalise and gonzales say well you could
just start there
what's your reaction no they're exactly
right i mean romanian mexico worked
building the fence worked and title 42
was working and
so they they need to reinstate those
fully but they also could reinstate
the agreements with the northern
triangle states of honduras nicaragua el
salvador
those were working how about taking away
incentives like fourteen hundred dollars
for every uh illegal migrant that comes
across the border
that would work and but you know what
would work is rhetoric the bully pulpit
if this president would say don't come
and then he enforces those policies
guess what
the cartels get that they control the
border right now and they would say
okay we're going to have to slow down or
we're going to find some other business
model but that's
that's what's happening this
administration
it indicates that they're willful harris
and
and look this is going to be costly for
democrats here's steve hilton from the
next revolution right here on the fox
network
first of all the issue itself is very
powerful as we saw
with president trump because it speaks
to people's concerns about
the government not being in control of
events but
secondly the crisis at the border caused
by biden's policies
that speaks to the incompetence the
general incompetence of the biden regime
and basically what steve and others have
been saying congressman is politically
this will start to really hurt and by
then
the nation will have been hurt well he's
right on that on two fronts first of all
this is a national security issue
we haven't even talked this morning
about the terrorists unknown watch list
that come across the border but it is a
political liability for them as well
you right now it is above 60 percent
so as people become more and more aware
and they've got to become aware because
you have
uh with uh apprehensions and getaways
that are coming in you're about a
quarter of a million people
per month over the last four months
that are coming into this country yeah
that's that's a million people
yeah i want to get to this house speaker
nancy pelosi
refusing to comment on congresswoman
ilhar omar standing
by her comparison of the us and israel
to terror groups like hamas and
the taliban this week omar took aim at
her jewish democratic colleague saying
they have not been partners in justice
and when she was asked about those
remarks yesterday
the speaker of the house cut the
reporter off mid question
watch very quickly um earlier this week
congresswoman ilhan omar was on our
let's stay with this and i'll answer
that
she and biden have that in common i
don't know if you caught his news
conference
earlier about that didn't have a lot of
news go back and forth earlier with
biden he was cutting questions off about
afghanistan what do you make of this
how can they hold ilhan omar accountable
if the speaker won't even let you ask
about it
yeah well the the media is asking the
right questions that they're not going
to answer them apparently
but it's consistent i mean this is not
like a one-off statement by
representative omar
this is a his this is a history and a
pattern i i
i typically will forgive somebody who
makes a statement that's inappropriate
one time you know you kind of look at it
you could get flustered to say something
you shouldn't say
but this is a pattern and and
the democrats speaker pelosi has allowed
this to go on for several years now
um and and she doesn't hold
well well my guess is that
that her power margin is so thin that
she can't afford to lose anybody
in order to remain the speaker of the
house of representatives and if
and if that's the case that's an
unprincipled i'm taking a cynical view
of things but i think that's the way it
is
imagine how thin that power margin is
going to be as we get closer to 2022 and
and you see people listening more to
republicans about
don't defund the cops and other issues
that people say
are atop their list of things they care
about congressman andy biggs of the
great state of my home of arizona it's
good to see you today happy fourth thank
you
happy fourth harris thanks